ja wir haben ja gerade schon die wut der
menschen dort in gütersloh hören können
bei den interviews insgesamt geht es
darum 370.000 menschen was natürlich
eine menge ist und es ist wenn man sich
jetzt mal die nachrichtenlage anschaut
eine welt news wir haben gerade breaking
news von bbc gesehen auch von afg also
es ist nicht nur für deutschland eine
große nachricht dass erstmals so ein
großer kreis wieder zurück führt
zumindest zu einer art kontakt
beschränkung nicht genauso wie vorher
wir haben gehört es soll eine
light-version seien aber dennoch ist es
natürlich psychologisch ein zeichen für
viele menschen ist könnte wie das
schlimmer kommen
auch für andere kreise welche rolle
spielt denn nrws ministerpräsident armin
laschet dabei wir haben ihn dort gerade
sehr entschlossen erlebt in dieser
pressekonferenz aber natürlich stellt
das für armin laschet politisch ein
großes problem dar denn er galt als
derjenige der bei den kontakt
beschränkungen eine schnellere öffnung
wollte hat sich sozusagen als der
personalisierte politiker hier
präsentiert der schneller zurück wollte
in den vergangenen wochen und monaten
zur normalität wir erinnern uns dort an
den streit mit dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten markus söder auch
mit der kanzlerin gab es probleme ja und
nun ist es ausgerechnet er der hier als
erster in deutschland als erster
ministerpräsident wieder einen ganzen
kreis zurückführen muss zudem lockdown
und ich gehe stark davon aus dass sich
der bayerische ministerpräsident
insbesondere bei dem rennen auch um die
frage der kanzlerkandidatur jetzt ein
wenig klammheimlich freut denn wir haben
in den vergangenen wochen und monaten
schon erlebt dass markus söder immer
wieder relativ spitz zum beispiel auf
heinsberg zu sprechen kam
mich würde es nicht wundern wenn markus
söder in den nächsten wochen das eine
oder andere mal auch wieder über den
fall güterslohs sprechen wird was denkst
du können es jetzt noch weitere lockdown
zu geben
das ist völlig offen es ist die frage
vor allem wie lange wird man dort in
gütersloh diesen locker und durchhalten
die sommerferien beginnen dort einen tag
bevor dieser lockdown zu ende sein soll
also am 29 juni
die frage ist wird sich sozusagen das
infektionsgeschehen noch weiter
ausweiten und natürlich ist es völlig
offen ob es auch in anderen kreisen zu
erhöhten fällen kommen wird und
sicherlich wird sich armin laschet die
frage stellen müssen und die frage
gefallen lassen müssen war das zu spät
wie er reagiert hat hätte er das ganze
schon früher anordnen müssen